there are more non-believers atheists
agnostics and so on than there are Jews
and blacks and gays combined and they
all have a voice at the table hi i'm tim
cavanaugh a reason TV we're here with
michael shermer publisher of skeptic
magazine and a columnist for Scientific
American thank you for joining us the
current issue of skeptic which I have
right here takes on happiness studies
and I mean it's all a bunch of crap
right for the most part the idea that if
you just will it to happen or you tell
children that their self-esteem should
be high and therefore it's high or or
you just tell the universe you want to
jagwire or whatever I mean it's it's
basically circumventing the way you
normally earn a living and earn
self-esteem the way happiness is
actually achieved is by just going out
and having productive work and a family
and friends and and just doing stuff how
about these you study you know sort of
cultural studies like where Bhutan will
come up as the happiest country on earth
income is only one factor obviously you
need 3 square meals a day and enough
money to have a roof over your head into
the basics of life people that don't
have that are truly less happy but once
the basics are met it turns out that
people can find all sorts of ways of
being happy without all the material
culture that we're used to part of the
issue though that complicates the
studies is that your baseline of where
you start depends on what culture you're
in so if you're used to making $40,000 a
year eighty thousand two hundred
thousand a year and you just sort of get
used to a certain baseline this is
called the hedonic treadmill get on this
treadmill of always chasing the value
above where you've been rather than some
baseline for just basic essentials the
hedonic treadmill though is that's why
evolution happens isn't it I mean that's
why people improve themselves for
because they're never content I think so
right our evolved propensity is to
constantly be searching even the most
basic stuff like hunger what hunger does
when you're low in calories is it makes
you more active well that's sort of
counterintuitive when you want to shut
the system down to conserve energy no
actually the more active you are the
more likely you are to get out there and
do something even something like
depression may be an evolved tool to
jolt you into making some major life
change
because the thing you've been doing just
isn't working as you sink lower and
lower in despair you really need to make
a major change job change career change
marital change you know something like
that you're not used to thinking that
somebody who's way in the dumps is
actually going to come up with the next
idea because they have no choice right
it's very difficult to predict of course
after the fact the self-help gurus
always tell the story the success
stories dropping out of college at read
for starting Apple or Harvard for
starting Microsoft that's the correct
pathway no that's actually not the
pathway statistically speaking to
college education will make you more
money than not having a college
education you're active in the Atheist
movement at least as a friend or fellow
traveler where are we with that in terms
of what percentage of Americans are
non-believers atheists whatever it
usually hovers around 10% slightly less
but if you expand it to include all the
sort of New Age Deepak Chopra type 2
spiritualism they don't believe in a
personal God that intervenes if we count
them that's more like 15 to 20 percent
if you're also throwing the people that
never go to church and don't care about
religion whether somebody believes in a
God or not I don't really care that much
it's what they do with that if it causes
them to fly planes into buildings or
blow up abortion clinics or or change
legislative policy or public school
what's taught in public schools stuff
like that now that that's a problem so
it's actually like 20 percent
well that's there's 300 million
Americans that's 60 million Americans
there are more non-believers atheists
agnostics and so and then there are Jews
and blacks and gays combined and they
all have a voice at the table they're
there at least there they get to vote on
things and they have a representative
and and we don't so it's you know it's a
consciousness-raising effort but the New
Atheism to say look it's not okay to say
these things about atheists anymore we
we're strong right okay what did you
think of a president amazement it's
awhile now and he's obviously
disappointed everybody since then but
that is inauguration singling out
non-believers as part of the amount was
great yeah we love that of course and I
mean like any politician he has to say
god Bless America because of the Muslim
stuff you had to come out it make a big
deal about his Christianity I don't
think it is a big deal for him and I
don't think it was before with say
Clinton even Reagan even
one before the rise of communism being
an atheist was not a big deal
communism was a state religion in a way
Marxism Leninism is a faux religion
so therefore atheism gets associated
with that and therefore like teaching
evolution makes you an atheist atheist
makes you a communist ergo we can't
teach evolution in public school this is
the mindset today that didn't used to be
there people have to remember wasn't
until the 50s that he put In God We
Trust on the coins and under God in the
Pledge of Allegiance only because of
this whole communism thing speaking of
things that religious people have
trouble with you've been thumping the
tub pretty effectively for the really
clear connection let's say between
natural selection and a free-market
economy that right-thinking people all
believe in Darwinism yet you nobody will
accept it like a unregulated market that
would be total chaos many people
companies over there over the head right
it's a curious thing but again I think
part of the problem is that most
academics and people in science are
liberals they don't see that there's a
connection between natural selection and
invisible hand
they just automatically distrust markets
they've just never learned how markets
really work it's not a perfect analogy I
mean we have to have there has to be
some rules by which the game is played
it'd be like playing sports without
rules no okay we have to have rules but
within the guidelines of how things are
done markets are the best tool ever
devised for generating wealth and
prosperity
what's the fallacy that you've discussed
when someone looks at a problem and they
can't imagine solving it oh yeah the one
fallacy is the argument from personal
incredulity because I can't think of the
solution then the can there can't be a
solution so educated and intelligent
people are especially bad about that
because that first of all they have big
ego second of all they know a lot and so
they can rationalize the beliefs they
already hold and then easily discount
the beliefs they don't want to believe
in and so that's part of a larger thing
called the the argument from ignorance
just because we don't know yet what the
solution is doesn't mean there isn't a
solution
just because evolutionists can't explain
say the chemical origins of life we have
about six different theories but we're
not settled on that yet it's okay that
doesn't mean that intelligent design is
correct
so that would be an argument from
ignorance so just because we can't think
of how an entire national police force
could operate
strict private industry and markets or a
military could be run privately or
something like that doesn't mean that
there isn't a solution
it's just that in our case there aren't
many people working on it I mean we
libertarians are all a number compared
to the vast sea state is skeptic is a
global warming acceptor that puts you at
odds with a lot of libertarians who are
I guess so in this case I just follow
the data I try to keep politics out of
it
I was originally a global climate
skeptic because of all the stuff that
happened in the 70s and 80s when I was
in college you know all the predictions
that were made all appalled erlik's doom
say stuff and he lost all those bets to
Julian Simon and boy I was right on
board with the skepticism and the killer
bees don't forget and there's lots of
examples of that okay so now actually
looking at the date I think there's
pretty good evidence that global warming
is real and at least partially human
caused after that I become more
skeptical
how much warmers are gonna get the error
bars grow wider the further the time
horizon is one of the consequence is
going to be integral of this warming
trend it depends on how much warmer
they'll get if it's just a fraction of a
degree probably no effects at all if
it's one or two degrees maybe moderate
effects what should we do about it well
I'm really skeptical about spending
trillions of dollars on a Manhattan
Project size government program to fix
it because most of the studies I've seen
show that spending trillions of dollars
will only bump down the levels of carbon
dioxide a tiny bit and change the say in
a hundred years or five hundred years
from now or a thousand years from now
the global climate by just half a degree
or one degree at most it would be nice
to get off fossil fuels anyway we have a
lot of work to do on that but hybrid
cars electric cars alternative fuels
these are good anyway
I think the Climategate email issue was
that I mean ultimately is that really an
ad hominem issue or is was there
something from that turns out there was
no big smoking gun in there
there really wasn't I mean I really
looked I followed that pretty closely
they get whoa this could this could
shift me back to skepticism there wasn't
much and all that really showed was that
scientists are are tribal like everybody
else they make fun of people they don't
like these be harshly of them you know
that everybody does that well you're the
skeptic at what point are we gonna run
out of stupid things and people
fortunately for my
job prospects for the future never
unfortunately for society this is always
going to be a problem the reason is in
short because we're pattern seekers why
people believe weird things it is
answered by why people believe things at
all and that is because that's learning
connecting A to B is just learning
problem is we don't have a baloney
detection module in our brain to say
that's a false positive it's a false
negative that's a real pattern that's
not a real pattern the only way that we
have is reason and science
[Music]